masta annoncé véhicules à partir de 139
dollars ou 2 semaines
à combien ça coûte exactement cette
information est inscrite nulle part
c'est illégal
la loi interdit au commerçant de passer
sous silence un fait important
maintenant chez albi en présente ces
trois véhicules au prix de 46 à 56
dollars par semaine
mais pendant combien de semaines devrait
vous pays cette information n'est pas
donné là encore la pub ne respectent pas
la loi
le nombre et la durée des périodes de
paiement doivent être indiqués quant à
cette pub elle n'est pas parfait kt ces
deux voitures ne sont pas les bonnes on
vous montre les modèles de luxe mais on
affiche de prix des modèles de base il
selon l'office de protection du
consommateur
cette publicité est trompeuse décidément
les fabricants et concessionnaires sans
avoir beaucoup de mal à dire les vraies
affaires